FIRST DEGREE MURDER CHARGE.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD LOOKS AT WHERE
THE KILLER GOT ONE OF THE GUNS.
>> Reporter: THE ACCUSED BUFFALO
GUNMAN APPEARING IN COURT TODAY
UNDER HEAVY SECURITY, HANDCUFFED
IN AN ORANGE JUMP SUIT.
HE HAS NOW BEEN INDICTED BY A
GRAND JURY FOR SATURDAY'S
GROCERY STORE SHOOTING THAT LEFT
TEN VICTIMS DEAD.
HE WAS CHARGED SATURDAY WITH
FIRST DEGREE MURDER TO WHICH
HE'S PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
OTHER CHARGES ARE EXPECTED TO BE
FILED, INCLUDING POTENTIAL HATE
CRIME CHARGES, WHICH WOULD
ALLEGE THE KILLINGS WERE
RACIALLY MOTIVATED.
AS HE WAS TAKEN OUT, AN ONLOOKER
CALLS HIM A COWARD.
HE FACES UP TO LIFE WITHOUT
PRISON IF CONVICTED.
SECURITY AT THE COURT WAS TIGHT
WITH POLICE DOGS AND HEAVILY
ARMED OFFICERS, AND THE SUSPECT
WAS BROUGHT IN BY TUNNEL.
HE CLAIMED ONLINE THAT HE GOT
ONE OF THE GUNS, A SAVAGE RIFLE,
FROM HIS FATHER FOR CHRISTMAS IN
2020.
A SAVAGE BOX CAN BE SEEN IN THIS
PHOTO.
A RIFLE WAS NOT USED IN THE TOPS
SHOOTING, BUT ONE WAS FOUND IN
HIS CAR.
THE HATEFUL RANT SAID THE GUNMAN
PLANNED TO USE THE SAVAGE RIFLE,
ALONG WITH A SHOTGUN, TO KILL
MORE BLACK PEOPLE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD, AS HE DROVE AWAY
FROM THE TOPS SUPERMARKET.
THE INVESTIGATION AT THE CRIME
SCENE IS FINISHED, BUT THE FBI
SAYS THE PROBE CONTINUES.
>> THERE ARE INTERVIEWS TO BE
DONE.
THERE ARE INFORMATION AND DATA
TO BE GATHERED FROM SOCIAL MEDIA
AND OTHER INTERNET COMPANIES.
THERE ARE ANALYSIS THAT NEED TO
BE DONE ON THE EVIDENCE THAT WAS
COLLECTED.
>> Reporter: JEFFREY PEACE IS AN
ADMINISTRATOR AT THE STATE
TABERNACLE CHURCH.
HE WAS A FELLOW DEACON THERE
WITH DECEASED HAYWARD PATTERSON
THERE.
I ASKED PEACE HOW PATTERSON
WOULD HAVE RESPONDED TO HIS
KILLER.
DO YOU THINK THAT DEACON
PATTERSON MIGHT FORGIVE THIS MAN
IF WE WERE ABLE TO?
>> THE BIBLE TELLS US TO
FORGIVE.
YOU KNOW, IT TELLS US TO
I CAN'T SPEAK -- HE'S GONE.
HE'S GONE.
BUT IF SURVIVING, YES, I WOULD
SAY YES.
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY YES.
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
FORGIVE THE GUNMAN, BECAUSE
WE'RE HERE.
>> Reporter: THE SON OF ANOTHER
VICTIM, SECURITY GUARD AARON
SALTER, JR., SAYING HE SURELY
SAVED THE LIVES OF OTHERS.
>> HE WENT OUT BECAUSE HE WAS
TRYING TO PROTECT EVERYONE.
HE MADE TOPS HIS PRIORITY.
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS RETIRED, HE
CARED ABOUT TOPS AND THE PEOPLE
WHO CAME IN THERE EVERY DAY.
HE CARED ABOUT THE EMPLOYEES,
AND IT WAS HIS DUTY TO KEEP
EVERYONE SAFE.
AND HE WENT OUT DOING THAT.
>> Reporter: JOHN PERSONS, THE
PRESIDENT AND COO OF TOPS
MARKETS, TOLD US THEY PLAN TO
REOPEN THE STORE, BUT HE COULD
NOT OFFER A TIMELINE ON EXACTLY
WHEN.
JAKE?
>> BRIAN TODD IN BUFFALO, NEW
YORK, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JOINING US NOW IS THE FORMER
COUNSEL TO THE ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
CARRIE, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
NEW YORK HAS A RED FLAG WAR WHO
BARS INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
ASSESSED BY A JUDGE FROM OWNING
A GUN.
THE ACCUSED WROTE AN ESSAY IN
SCHOOL ABOUT STAGING A
MURDER/SUICIDE.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT IT BY POLICE
WHO HAD BEEN ALERTED.
BUT NEITHER THE POLICE OR THE IN
EACHERS, NOR THE FACULTY, NOR
HIS PARENTS LET A JUDGE KNOW
USING THE RED FLAG LAW.
IT SEEMS OBVIOUS THEY SHOULD
HAVE.
BUT THESE LAWS ARE
UNDERUTILIZED.
>> THEY'RE UNDERUTILIZED AND
SOME OF THEM ARE RELATIVELY NEW,
JAKE.
SO IN NEW YORK, THIS LAW HAS
EXISTED FOR A FEW YEARS.
IN OTHER STATES IT'S BEEN JUST A
COUPLE OF YEARS.
ON ONE HAND WHEN WE LOOK BACK AT
IT, THERE'S SO MANY TRAGIC
ASPECTS OF THIS PARTICULAR
EVENT, ONE IS THAT THERE WERE SO
MANY WARNING SIGNS THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL EXHIBITED, AND HE
CAME TO THE ATTENTION OF ALL THE
AUTHORITIES THAT YOU WOULD WANT
SOMEONE LIKE TO COME TO THE
ATTENTION TO.
SO IT MAY BE THERE IS A MUCH
GREATER NEED FOR MORE TRAINING
AND AWARENESS, WHETHER THAT'S
FOR POLICE, WHETHER THAT'S FOR
SCHOOL OFFICIALS, WHETHER THAT'S
FOR PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY,
PARENTS, FAMILY MEMBERS, TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE THESE LAW
IT IS THEY NEED TO.
>> NOW, THE BUFFALO SUSPECT HAS
BEEN CHARGED IN NEW YORK WITH
FIRST DEGREE MURDER, ONE COUNT,
THAT COVERS TWO OR MORE MURDERS.
THE GRAND JURY IS EXPECTED, I'M
GUESSING, TO BRING MORE CHARGES.
WHAT MIGHT THOSE BE?
>> SO AT FIRST, THEY'RE GOING TO
BRING CHARGES JUST TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS INDIVIDUAL
STAYS IN CUSTODY SO THEY COULD
BRING ADDITIONAL CHARGES AT THE
STATE LEVEL FOR THE ADDITIONAL
MURDERS THAT THIS INDIVIDUAL HAS
COMMITTED.
THERE ALSO COULD BE AT THE STATE
LEVEL AN ADDITIONAL LOOK AT
CRIMES, AND WHOLE NEXT LEVEL IS
FEDERAL CHARGES, WHICH I WOULD
IMAGINE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
IS LOOKING AT AS IT RELATES TO
FEDERAL HATE CRIMES.
>> SO LAST NIGHT, THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES PASSED A BILL
AIMED AT COMBATTING DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
IT WOULD SET UP OFFICES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
TO FOCUS ON DOMESTIC TERROR AND
CALL FOR THE ASSESSMENT OF THE
THREAT POSED BY WHITE
SUPREMACISTS.
WHAT HAPPENED IN BUFFALO IS
HORRIFIC, BUT IT DOESN'T APPEAR
TO HAVE BEEN THE ACT OF A GROUP,
BUT THE ACT OF ONE DERANGED
RACIST.
WOULD THIS LAW HAVE HAD ANY
IMPACT?
WOULD IT HAVE PREVENTED THIS
TRAGEDY?
>> I THINK IT'S HARD TO SAY THAT
THIS PARTICULAR LAW, IF IT WERE
ENACTED, WOULD PREVENT THIS ACT.
IT WILL INCREASE -- IF THE LAW
ENDS UP BECOMING A LAW, IF THE
SENATE PASSES IT, IT WILL
INCREASE INFORMATION SHARING.
IT WILL FUND AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS BETTER RESOURCING AND
ATTENTION IN CONGRESSIONAL
OVERSIGHT OF ALL THESE DIFFERENT
GOVERNMENT COMPONENTS, WHO
ALREADY HAVE PEOPLE IN OFFICES
THAT ARE DEDICATED TO THESE
ISSUES ANY WAY.
I THINK THE LAW WILL HELP
CONGRESS DO BETTER OVERSIGHT
OVER THIS ISSUE.
BUT LOOK, THE KEY POINT THAT I
THINK THE COUNTRY IS STILL
DIGESTING IS THAT THE GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND AGENCIES IN
CHARGE OF THIS, AT THIS POINT,
ALTHOUGH THESE ACTS ARE
CONDUCTED BY AN INDIVIDUAL
IS INSPIRED BY THIS EXTREMIST
IDEALOLOGY, THIS IS PART OF A
BIGGER PATTERN.
SO IF WE LOOK AT THE MASS
MURDERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
WHETHER IT WAS THE TREE OF LIFE
SHOOTING, THE CHARLESTON CHURCH
SHOOTING OR WHETHER NOW IT IS
THIS ONE IN BUFFALO, THEY ARE
ALL ETHNICALLY, RELIGIOUSLY OR
RACIALLY MOTIVATED.
THIS IS BECAUSE THIS IS AN
EXTREMIST IDEALOLOGY PURR VADING
THE COUNTRY AND OT